no you don't to say something you always
want to say something what's he doing
what are you doing silly hello hello
YouTube will be working today with
opening presents
ok hello everyone a happy weekend super
exciting because I have been waiting for
my YouTube 100,000 subscriber present to
come and I recently got this box it says
it's from Indianapolis there's no
branding on here doesn't say YouTube
anywhere it's to my name and so I
started opening it up and then I feel
like I saw a youtube logo somewhere like
pulls it up I gotta make a video the
unboxing video now this isn't actually
the YouTube present then it's going to
be pretty embarrassing pretty bears so
we're gonna open up together yeah open
it up what you pull it up pull it up
this is our box there's still no YouTube
brand new on here oh it's got a lot of
little faces yeah but so here we go
let's pull off the lid block the lid
what does it the letter Willie little
sweet the letter letter hold on let me
read it you've just done something very
few YouTube creators accomplished you
had an astonishing 100,000 people
subscribed to your channel we know
numbers on YouTube can get really big
but we hope you don't lose sight of the
reality behind that six digit milestone
each and every person who has subscribed
to your channel was touched by what we
did they were inspired or challenge or
entertained inspired challenger
entertain Jaden's doing the entertaining
right now you made it to this milestone
with hard work perseverance and chances
are a healthy sense of humor what you've
accomplished can't be taken away from
you and we'd like to recognize you with
recognize you and all your hard work
with this silver play button a small
token of our esteem and respect
we know you don't do this for rewards
you do this because you have a drive to
create and share and because you found
the audience who cares believe us hey
they use believe I like that when we say
that we can't wait to see what you do
next a million subscribers may seem long
way off right now a million subscribers
is the next goal but you're closer than
you think and we're rooting for you
congratulations sincerely Susan watch
chickie I feel like I should know the
CEO of YouTube same but there it is
there it is ok ok he prays and go ready
gonna pull it up and wow just be a
finger can under mr. no no hold on let's
go busy it's in a frame oh it's in the
frame we should hang up there it is it
says modeling the Masters
congratulations hundred thousand
subscribers well I wish I had a friend
too I'm brain from me so thank you guys
for subscribing next one a million have
an amazing weekend what do you want to
say finish it off finish it off with the
frame thank you for watching continue to
believe and we'll see you soon